maduka kumari took out a loan from a
microfinance company
she pretty quickly became unable to make
the 30
monthly payments on those loans
and when she fell behind she started
getting visits from loan officers
and they became increasingly aggressive
demanding their money back
ultimately it led kamari to attempt to
commit suicide she poured kerosene over
her head and set herself alight
hospital
[Music]
microfinance was the development world's
attempt to help do away with poverty by
giving small loans to people in the
developing world in much of the
developing world people don't have
access to capital they call them
unbanked because they can't get bank
accounts so it started with this kind of
noble aspirations it began as a
charitable endeavor and it has since
morphed into something quite different
in many societies it's doubly hard for
women to get access to financial
services and microfinance was seen as a
panacea in terms of targeting women in
particular
what we found was a network of predatory
microfinance institutions operating
around the world who were promising to
lift people out of poverty and include
women in the financial services system
when in reality what they were actually
doing was forcing women to sell property
to repay small loans putting them in
prison in some instances and in sri
lanka more than 200 suicides have been
linked to microfinance loans
despite these problems it is still being
funded by public money and publicly
funded development banks
so public money that's supposed to be
helping the poor
is in some cases being given to people
who exploit them
is this esperanto
no
[Music]
modern microfinance traces its routes
back to the economist mohammad yunus who
in the 1970s
really pioneered this form of lending in
bangladesh after a devastating drought
there with no means of support and no
place to go they're in government camps
and his innovation was to lend these
people
small sums of money with low interest
rates
and they would build their businesses
on that investment and he found that um
actually it was very successful and
these people repaid their loans
and the global movement was born out of
that
i never had any intention or any plan or
thought that i would ever lend money to
become a banker of a sword
i was looking for opportunity to do some
tiny little thing which would be helpful
to another person
and one thing hit me very hard is the
victimization of people by the loan
sharks
giving tiny loans as little as one
dollar two dollar loan
and grab everything the other person has
and the poor people are desperate to
find some money for survival and so on
so they had to borrow money
seeing this repeatedly in the village i
was wondering whether i can protect them
from the loan shark
all people are entrepreneurs all they
need is money
money is the oxygen for entrepreneurship
[Music]
within a couple years you know he won
the nobel peace prize the u.n declared
it the year of micro credit because it
was the hot idea in the development
world
poverty is in the system so we sort out
the system correct those system nobody
will remain poor as a very simple logic
i believe that dr eunice is a person
that understands that love is a verb
that love is in action
this is an important trend in an era of
economic instability and entrenched
poverty
the clinton global initiative the gates
foundation matt damon bono i mean it
really captured the imagination of
people because it had everything that
you wanted it had profit you could make
some profit while doing good so that's
kind of the neoliberal dream and it also
uh depended upon
you know people being self-reliant and
everyone wants to think that you know
that little entrepreneurial spirit
can help people
what was particularly seductive about
microfinance was that the
microfinance institutions that receiving
government funding would one day
transition to profitability and have a
sustainable business model but by making
these institutions
profit-seeking there's an inherent
conflict there between doing social good
and making uh money
bangkok compared to almost really was
the big bang of commercial microfinance
it had been founded by a group of
religious people and it was a charity
but they wanted to scale up and they
thought the best way to do that was to
become commercial
they had an ipo in 2007 and a small
lender which had come to dominate
the microfinance world in mexico all of
a sudden had a valuation worth two
billion dollars
some of the ngos that had invested in it
like axion which is based in the us took
a million dollar public money from usaid
the u.s development agency invested in
compartmos and after the ipo boom they
had 350 million dollars worth of value
in it
it made a lot of people very rich
but it also in the financial world was
like ringing the dinner bell because
people saw how much money could be made
and so it changed everything
is
[Music]
i think the big hope was that by
bringing in the commercializing and
bringing in you know more capital you
could do more good but when big money
comes in it often demands big returns
and what we found is the world kind of
turned its attention away from it and as
that's happened the financial world has
continued to do it and
people's tax dollars are underwriting a
huge amount of it
in 2020 alone there was more than 50
billion dollars worth of committed funds
from development banks commercial
lenders non-governmental organizations
and socially minded impact investment
firms
that was a record
sri lanka is a country where the
consumer protections are very sparse and
there is a burgeoning micro finance
industry there
lending ever larger amounts of money to
poor mostly financially illiterate
people who are getting stuck in a
vicious cycle of debt
lolc started out as a leasing company in
sri lanka with the backing of the world
bank in the 1980s
it has since morphed into one of the
world's biggest
microfinance lenders backed by hundreds
of millions of dollars of financial
assistance from pretty much every
development bank that you can think of
for the next generation
a new dawn has arrived
full of promise
today lolc is sri lanka's most
profitable listed company
and its owner is one of the country's
richest men and the lion's share of that
money has come from microfinance
from lending to poor people
there's very little regulatory oversight
of these microfinance institutions and
so what you find is that they are
operating really on their own terms
we found multiple instances of lolc
microfinance companies using pressure
tactics to
force women to to repay money that we're
leading these women into real despair
and
torment
[Music]
foreign
be
[Music]
cambodia became the first foreign market
that lolc expanded into
it bought a stake in a microfinance
lender there called prasak which was
co-owned by a bunch of development banks
cambodia has become a poster child for
what can go wrong with microfinance it's
one of the world's poorest countries and
now one of its most over-indebted
in cambodia loan sizes have ballooned
over the past decade and now more than
one in five adult cambodians has a
microfinance loan
[Music]
which is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
not in my wildest dream that i thought
our work would be used
by someone to make themselves loan
sharks
so that's a very sad part of the story
you are driven by self-interest and this
is translated as maximization of profit
so basically you became uh money-making
robots and you can destroy all the poor
people's lives you don't care this
because you make money
when you make the point to many people
in the development banking world that
there is little evidence to show that
microfinance has achieved its aims of
lifting the poor out of poverty they
often say that it's much better than the
alternative which is
that these poor people would have to
resort to loan sharks while that's
difficult to dispute it really doesn't
justify the hundreds of billions that
has been put into this industry with
very scant evidence of it having any
long-term impact
the us government the british government
the world bank proparco the french bank
they give to different banks and when
you ask them well why did you give to
this lender
who has a history of forcing people to
sell their land and of throwing people
into debtors prison and they'll say oh
we didn't know that that someone else
was supposed to vet it and ultimately
they can just pass the buck of
responsibility onto someone else
no one wants to say what is an
acceptable amount of interest and what
is an acceptable amount of profit level
for a
lender that says it's a socially minded
institution so people all just kind of
look the other way and i think people
don't want to reckon that because
there's a lot of people making a lot of
money off
[Music]
you